what happened to dad with akathisia it  was so bad it was every doctor we went  to and it was like him too being like  I'm done I'm done like I'm gonna die I'm  done and then I was there being like no  absolutely [ __ ] not you're not gonna  die like this is a drug thing and your  brain can heal it almost left him to be  tortured every day from Psych Med  effects in an asylum it was like two and  a half years like that could have been  my parents lives like my dad in a  hospital actively being tortured from  the side effects my mom bringing him  food every day from medications he just  needed to be taken off of I'm pissed off  about it so that's why we started we  started to talk about it too it's like  if there are other people going through  this they just need to know that they  have to wait they just have to get  through it and they're going to be okay  afterwards